this video contains spoilers for the
batman you've been warned hello everyone
i'm alana and welcome to my channel
where today i am finally talking about
the batman um anyone who knows me knows
i'm a very big batman fan i've been
reading batman comics for
almost 20 years now so i've had a lot of
people ask me how i felt about this
movie and um
i unfortunately didn't love it
i still am not entirely confident in how
i feel about it i'm going to see it
again this week um
just to kind of like reassess some stuff
it was strange when the credits rolled i
just kind of sat there in silence
staring at them and was like huh
okay
um
so to touch on some of the stuff that i
liked to start with there's some stuff
that i think they did amazingly well
there were just a few things that really
stopped me from being able to love it
unfortunately so
i think the tone of gotham
was awesome um
the portrayal of gotham itself is the
most accurate that i've ever felt it's
been i feel like they've really got the
atmosphere of a very
grimy crime-ridden city in a way that
doesn't feel too expositiony which is a
thing that i feel like some other um
batman related media falls into so
loved gotham
i also love the style of film
this is effectively a detective noir
film um there are so many superhero
movies now obviously and i feel like it
has almost become its own genre where
they follow this really specific
three-act structure
um they have very similar senses of
humor
that you could almost predict when the
action scenes are gonna show up
this didn't do that at all similar to
joker i'm so glad for that that this
movie
is not a superhero movie um obviously
batman's not technically a superhero
anyway but he is a hero slash vigilante
it still didn't it didn't fall into that
formula uh so i was so happy about that
it's it's more like
seven than
any other um
genre movie like any other i guess uh
batman film
any other superhero movie in a way that
i really really enjoyed they
finally gave us a yeah dark you know
noir detective batman
who's obviously very angry in a way that
is a bit more complex than just
justice obviously he still very much
cares about justice that is established
in this film
but um
tapping into the emotions a little bit
more was very interesting to me too so
i liked how they delved into that um i
thought that a lot of the performances
across the board were very very very
good uh
i would say not a weak performance
everyone was fantastic um i feel like
penguin
was especially incredible and it is so
funny considering how attractive
colin is under that makeup
he just he did such a good job that he's
like unrecognizable i thought that he
was absolutely brilliant um
paul dano is one of my favorite actors i
think he's like
so
i don't know
just hard to even take your eyes away
from when he's on screen he's so
engrossed oh hello he's so engrossing to
watch um that
yeah he's one of my favorite actors and
i did feel like he
was a little bit too much
it's a complicated role that's that's my
the only actor that i was not a fan of
is funnily enough like in my top three
favorite actors
right now
um just a little bit over the top i felt
uh which i think probably just comes
with the nature of that character and
and so much of what he did was recorded
solo um you know a lot of the stuff on
iphones or video vlogs or whatever
he's effectively performing a series of
monologues outside of the rest of the
film so
that certainly had to be a challenge um
just a little bit too much for me i
think just a little bit too over the top
and it's certainly hard not to draw
comparisons to
heath ledger's joker
um
yeah it's not the usual riddler
and i feel like i should stay early in
this video i don't care about that i uh
if you have been on my channel for a
while you will know that i
always make an effort to let
different forms of medium be different
so as a huge batman fan i mean obviously
this movie
is greatly inspired by long halloween
that seems very clear to me
and i know that that's generally how um
these ips get written is that the
writers who usually would be film
writers or tv writers not necessarily
batman fans um
this is obviously not talking about this
movie but just in general just go read
the most popular comics or the most
beloved ones it's clearly very long
halloween but um i don't care at all if
things are not the same that doesn't
bother me in the slightest as a batman
fan as a comic fan in general as a video
game fan anytime anything gets adapted i
don't care they don't have to be the
same if i wanted the exact same thing i
would just go read the comics again so
note that is my stance on that i have no
criticisms about things being different
it just doesn't matter to me at all
um
of course i'm gonna like some like fan
service type stuff where they give me
little bones of like
part of the movie alluding to hush was
very interesting to me and very exciting
to me
um but just to get that out of the way
i'm never gonna criticize it for doing
things that aren't the same as the
comics in general um
with with one exception but i will get
to that uh it's just one exception
that's so hard for me to forget um
so yeah it did feel a lot like
paul dano's riddler was a bit too
similar to heath ledger's joker which
you can't really criticize the film for
because they are separate things
but he's definitely not the standard
riddler that we're used to seeing
um
they really went hard on the sort of
in-cell vibes
he was definitely
interesting um just yeah a little bit
over the top for me
i thought catwoman was incredible
and the chemistry between
batman and catwoman in this movie is
like nuts what an incredible job of
portraying sexual chemistry between two
characters
without
ever actually having them do anything
more than sort of a light kiss um
that i don't even know how they did that
that was amazing it's a spicy film
but yeah i thought she was absolutely uh
amazing and good performances generally
across the board other stuff i liked um
i thought the action
was
like some of the best uh of any batman
film i i thought the action
how brutally he carries himself um
battenson
that is how how angrily and brutally
he carries himself is just like
so
enthralling to watch um
like he's almost killing people in a way
that's like damn you are
angry my friend and they did such a good
portrayal of that i also love that the
suit
when he steps a lot of the time it's you
know a logic leap that sometimes he's
silent and sometimes he's very loud but
the thugs he takes a step and his feet
stud i was like oh that's so
intimidating which is like paired with
the beginning of the movie
how they really set up how all the
criminals in gotham feel about batman in
a way that i really enjoyed which is
they just assume he's in every
dark part of the city and then he's
hiding in every shadow and when they see
him they're terrified and i thought that
that was
awesome um
would have liked maybe a little bit more
action potentially considering the
length of the film
um but
for the most part i thought it was
fantastic i really liked
the look style
um and a lot of the shots in the movie i
think i probably could have used
slightly less of the like i don't know
what it's called when the camera is like
on the person
uh shots but for the most part i thought
it was absolutely beautiful like
breathtakingly beautiful and yeah like i
said
love this iteration of gotham thought it
was absolutely awesome
i also
really liked the plot
the actual plot um which is so rare for
any of these comic book movies they tend
to hinge a lot more on characters than
plot and generally that's like the
suggested way to write something is you
focus on characters more than plot but i
was actually actively interested in the
plot
in
who the rat was um
how corrupt
the city actually was who was in charge
i was i was very into that
and the plot twist
of the riddler
not actually knowing that bruce wayne
was batman was also
very cool i thought that that was great
um so i was like super into the
the context of the plot in a way that i
never would have even expected going in
because yeah often i just feel like
these movies aren't really treated with
that level of intelligence so
appreciated the hell out of that um
trying to think about other stuff that i
really liked i mean there's loads of
stuff that i liked it's just that the
things that i didn't like
bothered me
enough that i was like ah bummer like
and i feel like these kind of things hit
harder when when you see so much good in
something and there are a few things
that you don't like and it really like
makes you think oh so close so it kind
of hits harder it's harder to be um
ambivalent about it's harder to not care
about it's you just feel more invested
when you're like damn it you almost had
me
so i'm sure that there's stuff that i
liked about it that i'm
forgetting that i just haven't thought
of
but there are there's a ton to love um
my biggest problem with it
was
i felt like it was trying so hard to be
edgy
that i found it cheesy
and
this is just a natural reaction that i
had you know like in the theater i was
sitting there and i was like
like a number of times just like oh just
at things like i said trying very hard
to be edgy
in a way that i just found very
off-putting i was like oh god like
i would have written something like that
in my diary when i was a teenager
um
and it's like hard to levy criticism at
that
other than to say that was just my
reaction and i couldn't turn that off
uh
yeah it's like they just
there was so little levity from that and
it took itself so seriously in a way
that um
obviously like
tonally
these most recent dc movies
have changed a lot like oh really i'm
just talking about joker and and i guess
a little bit but to pray a little bit um
and batman
you know pulled from things like taxi
drive i've pulled from classic films
this is obviously pulled from seven
but
just everybody being so gritty seven is
not like that you know just every single
person
like the fact that commissioner gordon
even kind of speaks in a batman way like
even he's like yeah we gotta figure out
the crime like it's why
there was just
uh unfortunately way too many moments
that i just felt like
very heavy-handed and um
just like so emo which is like
i want serious for sure i never felt
that way watching seven uh
yeah just some stuff that that really
killed me there was one part that i
laughed out loud at in the theater
which was the whole el rada thing and
when
batman goes u r l
and then goes to type [ __ ] in i was just
like
url
oh god okay and that happened more than
once um unless there's some context
where that is supposed to be funny and i
was just the only person in the theater
who laughed at it i just it's just so
cheesy that happened a number of times
unfortunately just
they just laid it on a little bit too
thick for me and of course i understand
a lot of people probably don't feel the
same way and didn't have that problem
with it but
i can't change
how i reacted to that really i just um
i love gritty and i love dark
it just felt like it was pretending to
be gritty and dark sometimes in a way
that just didn't feel authentic and thus
came across as very cheesy to me which
is unfortunate
the one thing that i
disliked
um which
could be rooted in me being such a big
batman fan
or or maybe it's just the logic of the
film
is that
i've always like kind of been a little
bit annoyed when they don't portray
batman as a good detective
um batman is very smart bruce is very
very smart right
in this movie he's not a good detective
he doesn't actually solve
the things he needs to um there's one
instance where a very important puzzle
piece is just sold by a guy being like
oh yeah my uncle works in carpeting or
whatever
but batman didn't even solve that he
didn't even go this is the murder weapon
what is it let me scan this alfred this
is what this is what you know like this
is so many and he was just like probably
there for no reason like
really um but he didn't actually solve
anything he failed at the end of the day
he failed
uh the bombs went off the city was
flooded
he failed and
that could be very interesting if there
were any kind of character arc tied to
that which potentially we could see in
further films
but for this film as it stands to me it
was just like
okay batman was not smart enough to
figure this out again the only thing you
really see him be a good detective at um
from what i recall again it's like when
you just see something once this piece
is missing and i want to see it again
but um
he's just really good at riddles
he's just really good at figuring out
the answers to riddles like like my
grandma
like my 95 year old grandma
she's very good at riddles
batman also very good at quickly
answering riddles
even the ciphers like alfred
helps with you know um
which like i really liked andy circus i
thought that this iteration of alfred
was awesome as well i really liked a lot
of the characters actually
but just yeah having a film where he
basically fails right he loses he fails
but not for a reason that feels in any
way compelling um especially because i
didn't care about bruce at all i feel
like my initial concerns were basically
correct which is that
this version of bruce was just too emo
for me and that was part of the like it
being two edge lord thing was i was just
like he's just too
he's just too emo and that was my
reactions to the initial trailers and i
really hoped that i would be wrong
um and that's not to say he shouldn't be
obviously this is year two batman you
know he still hasn't figured out his
bruce wayne persona clearly and that's
something he'll grow into
but
it
he was just a nothing of a character
ultimately like i felt like bruce wayne
outside of showing some of that anger
and having the context of like i'm
trying to maintain my father's legacy
and this is complicated or whatever
just
he really just is an emo kid um
it was unappealing so then when you go
through this this
situation where he's failing the riddler
is effectively beating him and i i did
love the twist of really thinking they
were working together i thought that was
great too
but that he he fails at everything
doesn't figure anything out in a way
that's ultimately helpful um the riddler
tricks him into you know the bringing
into the light thing
um
and then it's not for any character
growth or for any sort of resolution um
because obviously seven is a very good
comparison in seven
they ultimately fail in that movie but
the reason and the way that they fail
is
fantastic they even their failure was a
trick right so like the failure in seven
is i'm going to bait you into being so
angry that you commit the final sin for
me and that that worked
is such an interesting
arc i mean that seems fantastic
whereas this
it felt like he just failed and i guess
you could make the case for like sure
but then gotham will be rebuilt but it
also leaves you with the anecdote of
catwoman being like it's gonna suck
anyway it's gonna be the same place
you'll just see everybody else groveling
so the whole city's been flooded
a lot of people are dead a lot of people
so many people died there's just no way
they didn't i mean the in-cell rifleman
had to have taken some people out
um
not entirely sure how the mayor lived
was she wearing
bullet vest or something i don't
whatever i'll figure that out next time
i watch it um
but
yeah there there was so
so much failure for somebody who never
figured anything out who never actually
resolved anything and when it ends
it's just kind of like
okay
okay yeah city bad
really don't like city
you failed um which just kind of makes
the ending i think
i think it's probably more of an issue
that there's there's there's no arc
where that's concerned or no like tidy
up it's not that he needed to succeed
again just fail in a more interesting
way or like fail as a consequence of
something fail for some reason that you
learn from or that you were tricked into
rather than just like well you didn't
think to do the carpet thing to figure
it out in time
um i would have just like something more
interesting and i think that maybe i
only feel that way about the ending
because
the ending felt a little bit sloppy um
the pacing sort of was a little bit of
an issue towards the end i think and uh
a lot of just sort of pieces thrown in
together that that
maybe that
amplified that i guess um
yeah i mean it's a really long movie
obviously um
my i didn't actually have a problem with
the length for the most part but my
biggest complaint about the length was
i think how frequently they played the
batman theme started to drive me nuts
their version of the batman theme was
played so frequently that i was like
i get it
slightly less like is it 20 times it
seems like it happened so often
um
there are a couple of other things that
i like slightly disliked that are just
really nitpicks like
the part where you get shot behind the
car that catwoman is also hiding behind
with the dead body inside the car
and then just like suddenly he's in the
batmobile
but to get there in theory he would have
had to have run across everybody and
it's like sure it's batman he could
figure it out but how did that happen
just stuff like that that i'm like
were you not gonna explain that because
it would have been very cool actually to
see him figure out how to get to the car
slash why the car was there like to put
that all together i guess again unless i
missed something on my first viewing
just like minor nitpicks like that that
i was like wait a minute what
um
like i felt the same way about like
sending the bomb to bruce wayne when
everybody else was so meticulously
carefully killed
obviously he's a recluse and doesn't go
out very much and you could argue you
could you could make [ __ ] up you could
be like maybe
wayne matter is like really heavily
guarded he didn't think he could get in
but it just seems so odd to treat him so
differently to everybody else
i mean
the motive for that is very different
too it's like he's uncovering corruption
um
for the most part riddler but where it
comes to bruce wayne it seemed more like
a jealousy thing he was like since the
father sure but somebody who's so
specific about uncovering corruption and
is so
clearly calculated in picking people who
are associated with a particular set of
wrongdoings
just kind of going for somebody's
son
i get that they built in that he was
jealous of him and all that context i
understand that too
um
but it just was like a little bit
disconnected again that's just like a
minor nitpick that i was just like what
but he's so driven in this one pot and
then he just has this one exception
that's like who's jealous of person
that's fine uh not a huge deal
i'm trying to think of other things
yeah obviously when i go see a movie
like this i'm not planning to review it
so i'm not like taking notes in my head
i just saw it you know as someone who is
excited to see it
um
i thought the thumb drive thing was very
funny
i actually really liked and i know some
people laughed but i actually really
liked the wingsuit and seeing him
terrified that's the year 2 batman thing
that i found very interesting and then
like when he
pulls a parachute and smacks himself i
actually really liked that
and then he injures himself my only
issue with it is that he wasn't injured
the next day
that it was just that and then it was
done like i would have loved to have
seen him like batter himself a little
bit because i think that is also like an
interesting facet of year 2 batman
that um he was just fine afterwards
because like if you read year one which
you know this is obviously also
definitely inspired by
he does get the crap beat out of him and
you do have to watch him like clean
himself up and stuff
uh but he was just he was completely
fine after a fall like that man come on
uh but again these are all very minor
knit picks i think it was it was mostly
yeah just laid it on a little bit too
thick for me i think with the
the edgy content which i love an ng film
usually like i'm a big fan of stuff
that's gritty and serious
uh for the most part probably more than
any other kind of film so
it just seemed like
yeah ultimately my initial concern i was
correct about which is that i was
worried about
emo batman
i didn't like the way that he looked
and i still don't and i didn't like the
the iteration of bruce wayne again i get
he's still growing into figuring out his
public playboy persona but that doesn't
make him any more interesting
um or likable or enjoyable to watch or
make you care about him i didn't really
connect to a lot of batman's motives uh
outside of knowing them because we all
know who batman is obviously
um
trying to think of other stuff but right
now i've been talking about this for 22
minutes already apparently so what i
will probably do is like potentially do
a second viewing update video um
to see if my mind changes but for the
most part yeah there was a lot that i
liked i liked more than i didn't like
it's just the stuff that i didn't like
stopped me from loving it that's all it
is he's like i still liked this movie i
think
i really want to watch it again and like
re-reassess it
but um
i definitely didn't love it dark knight
is still my favorite batman movie and
one of my favorite movies ever
i've seen that movie in cinemas more
than any other film it's like probably
like 20 times now it's pretty excessive
um
yeah i think that that's
i probably forgot loads of stuff but i'm
not going to keep you guys any longer
thank you for watching uh please don't
yell at me
different different opinions
uh okay if you loved it that is cool
with me if you hated it that is also
cool with me
um again i'm a huge batman fan and that
hasn't
ever faltered it's been such a long time
so
i'm gonna keep reading my comics and and
i'll watch another one if they come out
with it um i i will always watch them if
they're gonna stop doing that either it
just
um yeah maybe went a little bit too far
in one direction that i felt like it was
just trying too hard to be edgy rather
than just like organically being a dark
serious film
i think that is my take um thank you
guys for watching i will see you next
time